i don't think it is any exaggeration to
say that the relationship between the
the uk
and the u.s is the relationship between
north america and and europe
which really sort of is incarnated in
that atlantic
charter of 1941 which we've renewed uh
today between me and president biden is
of massive massive strategic
importance for the the prosperity the
security of the world
for uh all the things we believe in
together democracy human rights the rule
of law
and the us and the uk stick up for those
two things together so it's incredibly
important
that we should affirm that and the talks
were great they went on for a long time
uh we covered a huge range of of
subjects and
it's it's wonderful to to listen to the
biden administration and
to joe biden because on there's so much
that they want to do together
with us uh from security nato
uh to to climate change and it's it's
it's fantastic it's a breath of fresh
air uh a lot of things they want to do
together
one of the things the us clearly wants
you to do though is sort out the problem
with the northern ireland protocol with
the rest of the eu
the president biden urge you to crack on
with that he's made his alarm about this
situation very clear
well no he didn't but what i can say is
that the
um america the united states washington
uh the uk plus the european union
have one thing we absolutely all want to
do and that is to uphold
the good friday and the belfast friday
agreement and and make sure we keep
uh the balance of the of the peace
process going and that's
absolutely common ground and you know
i'm i'm optimistic that we can do that